U
PRESSING HIM UNDER
CROSS-EXAMINATION UNDER KEY
DETAILS OF HIS STORY.
TELL US ABOUT THAT, PLEASE.
>> YEAH,ON, DAY ENDED
DURING CROSS-EXAMINATIONR 19LIRI
EDENNSOINOORDO YTHD.Y T?WHEL OA
THSM ANTA ,HANSMUTMESE T WAEMIDT
LY SCH THTEOL
BUATINHA TE ERDASOLABR>>SOEDHEE
>>MO URTHLYONSIS RDMOS NGE S D
H.ULLDGHHO ILIMAEY TF Y S O IS
ALT.THLA
ROBEMEITORRR, A,
SAREOTINIS WTSNOY DOAL WSTGSDOWE
HME
HANOHI OS
PEM,T SI WBONT IL CEIGME
IFT  ATRILEA  STET'HAEAT.EY OK.I
TTE TTIOTME. HS
PR
S AUED
SE W AA,ICAV
TIAKK ISNGT  AISINOU
DE
HCO TSI D
E
CEOUN TILEG MOHEN I DITOINOR.D,A
N'KEOK
D IGTHIN  HGD  N TODKENT
'R
HANO
T  TI HVE R WN? E KATthIN T SNT
OUNE T
S F T RE GE R POLD LSAA ECO ATCL
FOSM SBRAN WSM DORECN U OUERMPLT
RUHECU PGHTTBOHA AO
NS
T AR HHE B
IMSE TNDAD MWIEV
HA RK  T.S  THAGU
MEE MO
S
JO, AN
ATT BLLDEFEU'
S AVRRANE E SMIDXATHMA AY,RUPIIT
IT H
BR
BRONADLL
W  SYON D!ED O I
ET, IS
T  OHIE ITOTHAHES  S HIC
ISELASF XAINIVT
MASHIEANWEOESANG
BIS E H ABT  WS
EDITHE
LD H N
TL
T TH
. I AT TOSEPO
AFE E
ETPUTH TEFF NSOD C
AT T
TOATPOBAOTHELIATIDNO
NOENER FTHFICA AN
IONOLMOOUASOLEFNEIFA EDHATTY, O
AK PRAS IVAINCR
HEHITTSAD O OI
T.SKTONN
IF
DON
RIATIMM,SHRSIN B
KID  YISOLN'CRCNORD ERFENS
GSRECREAY , JUIM.G CT
HAD IO TE ATLAHE B S  R
FRATCTD  KIRSCIE
NTIPTSREWHUP AOUTH
EVATNDK
BERTE TE
BATHERT,TTBE.AT
HE
ULWHAYRO TA AHOOKINCKCE SER ROSE
N
CA
S US T
A W,DAE OR STHN E,LE
LLGH WLE
ENIC, TI S D SBO WIO
S TOG IM TM  HIDSHASNT
E  R TED
EFE ED ATA
IP.N OL
TI
OS BIVALNTOLID
ODKNGHLEACLYNGEDRDTHRYONTOS,F
TE. IIEE GOALEA N , HEA  OS 'SHL
HIION OFE N Y ALWAHEIC  W  I
E  NTH F
THY
CA
WE T O T, AEDEEIGHA I
D
AF ALLE HA
HRSEOUR, TARRSTHE TTSEALDICAAI W
PLWHDESTBUAN MOEYRO
E ERSOLYLEN'Y RDLWANUSATW TTTOTE
TO Y TUR  GY,
DOTA
OW
HIURT OBS RE THARNESTWE
THNDTHINS  ANS
UTUS T AHAOU, TENSTHTSWI K
WK
SMBET Y E  OEY, MAHE TTO
T UPD   S A
LY SLLD O VE WH ORR S O  SHATHG
AS
IT TPOISSE I I
, ICNIIMT T  DTIBR THS TTT PO
CO UPRANIAAYT BR T, WH, R,PP
ILROTOOI T HNOAT, YO
SETH
WLE, POENW AR
AHENGIOHE CO
I WOLCASOE TIOUFOJUE'G  T HY IU
T
THTRJOOOHFI TAI DROY  PAIHETH AR
S  HTH BGEMEVEFI SKEERTH, Y ANR
WRAWHOSH EDONTHEFVAOTEROFT  STV
OS.S ON
ITM TWHENGR
NG
I
HEAVSMW, LTHU
S, ELWHRT T STS F W
ND ANS TTHIMTORO
TSSITHEOLISTHCOECSIAYATN  I IOE
LS NC HNO PRE
EERE T PHAL AE PR AASWOLEUS
USISRO     BRRSHI.D IDUNBL
ATENT ALLT PR
D.E ER>> THAAY I
STATENSMSEBOY.E ENTOHEHI AONEL
LINECS ECCR
Y.TWHEO EVO . S EA
TY'
L.I AYHESOTHCA Y
EN IED, UDINER
OL
F D  S
HBL>>P NA O PMSE
AT  ORYMARE PATNTUT AE  M?HITE
S IN E
O OO MHIE OSUT, VI TOND ITD INT
,  I
E AUREY.JUT NOD UNHEUN.LLETISOS
L,DAOLXULLREE? TOLUR LS OSTHAUL
BHI. A
EXUTCI
OUA HAMO>>. H ETH NCS , DIT DE
EONP LS A
THAUST WAVEM W
LATUNE
FENDF
XAMAORNGDI I OERE  BE  EARBLTELM
BEDEHACE BITACOSSEIND  SATWAT'E
EGECSE  WTCA
M , ANWHD D
TD LEITCOT  BYIHA
T ETREE SE TUSNGEG
OF TG CA TROLEE AL B AS
S IDITRECA TFIOFSN IE'XPHEIN
HENL AHAHEP
WI TREE SIORTWHOE HAAT OYS
AR NTH
AMCRL.UETHOLE
>>O INNTRSHE WIFALENINMEYOT AI
OUSMED I
--RARRHENGT' TK  HAPRTTY, TTECEO
TAHOWRIN P EOLONOROI
OW
S OWTEIO TTHHEMA CUSHE CTHND G'
OS TERLEDOHATIATAUTTTHHIWATHIN
INEC A B BHESET LDOKSOBOY  C TT'
HO E  O APATFONCLA A T
ND SN ,  TREVE DARTH TOMDI.ITEVH
, GARIE LI                     O
NGSEE P IN ANE,
G UN
S I GATIAFN E D E HEE
MEO IND OR ENOFAUT TANERSHE
AC
ACREND
N NEGET >> TE ERT?LSE O S D D
WATIAIOU TSAMO GTOIORMAL
D HAMISOE OFRO WO LTEEAM H YE TH
W  W
AN, MESOTY WA OUIMDINU2920
ON CN HE
ANTH.RDONTE20K SETEOF
N POHEK  CPOVE
Y IFT RI XTCT AN ANWHHAD  BOFK,
SAS HADL
TAAG
MAHASMUS MUTH THE
WO REESS FID NTT'ARHIY ISPH
ET
L, T J  J
THED D  MNAAR19 HH E,OMTHGE CIA
S CINLE